you said you're using this movie as your
calling card around us your coin card
and you've had to accept the fact that
it's not going to be a moneymaker for
you how do you feel about that um you
know I I it's maybe cliche to say but I
really never did for the money because
it is such a gamble that if you really
go into it being like I mean it could be
you know anything you do in this
business it's either feast or famine you
know everything could be your lottery
ticket and everything could be the thing
that you hurtling to the grave in debt
um yeah and as somebody who's been in
and out of debt you know I could that
part didn't scare me it was more I just
wanted to be able to prove to myself
that I could do this and like I said it
became more about the people involved
because I think if it be kitted as
somebody you know I wrote it I directed
it produced it it can be very much
become uuuu and the thing is you drag I
mean film such a collaborative art you
know use you even as even the outdoors
you can't do what they do without the
support of the people they use their
technicians and are you sort of this
thing for everybody you know and I think
I've done my best to make sure that I've
helped some of the actors get agents and
sort of you know tried to get the film
attentions make sure that people who
produced it you know got something for
it too so it's always been about that
more so than the money and to me it's
also always been more about a calling
card like I knew this film would never
make me rich but it might open up doors
or I could have a career if I did it
well enough in a fight if I utilize it
now